strolling calmly into a conference that
was on the brink of chaos before it had
even begun jeremy corbyn's team claimed
he was unaware of last night's attempts
to topple his deputy but he wouldn't
confirm that as he arrived in Brighton
when did you first know about the plot
to ask Tom Watson the NEC agreed this
morning that we're going to consult on
the future of diversifying the deputy
leadership positions to reflect the
diversity of our society and our comfort
we'll move on that intervention meant
Tom Watson arrived in Brighton still in
places deputy he too had questions about
how much the leader knew of the aborted
plot against him I don't know what
Jeremy knew and didn't know do you think
this is the end of it
well I hope it is because you know we're
just for the party conferences voting on
rule changes now and I want this week to
be the most positive week we could have
I want us to unify our ways to talk
about what our vision for the country
during and after a general election is
but that's gone hasn't it that
opportunity is gone well we've had a bad
start to our conference I can't do
anything about that the move against mr.
Watson was launched by John Landsman the
founder of the grassroots campaign group
momentum with the backing of some trade
union figures and other Corbin loyalists
he wanted the deputy leader role to be
abolished removing from post a man they
claim is intent on destabilizing the
leadership mr. Colby mr. Landesman
acting on your blessing were you in a
position this morning which the party is
consulting on a future and more diverse
establishment of deputy leadership
positions in the party the NEC is united
on that and I'm very happy we're now
moving forward you can see it's
distracted attention from policies you
wanted to know well the questions that
you asked a good ones because the issues
are austerity poverty a No Deal brexit
and the Prime Minister shuts and
Parliament to avoid discussion
so that's a misjudgment by John Landsman
would you concede that following the
decision John Landsman posted on social
media saying he fully supported the
review but there was no acknowledgement
of the anger his bid had caused during
criticism as it did from former leaders
Blair Brown and Miliband
backbenchers and even some in the shadow
cabinet I would have thought a move to
abolish a constitutional position in a
lone party without any discussion with
my constituency Labor Party about any
discussion with a rider labor movement
across the country it's not what we want
to be doing when we should be fighting
the Tories at this conference little
surprise then that the decision to
withdraw the motion and replace it with
a longer term review left other senior
figures seemingly relieved
I mean you pleased with the resolution
that Jeremy came to in the end I think
it provides a way for and you want to
see Tom Watson carry on do you want the
review to what you want from the review
on the face of it momentum sources say
they were concerned that the deputy
leader might be planning to wreck the
party's chances in any upcoming general
election but there are people here
wondering whether there is a difference
underlying motive to prevent on what
from being in the position where he
would become acting leader Jeremy Corbyn
was a step down the very fact that
scenario might be being considered jars
with what this conference was supposed
to be about and the leader setting out
his vision for a country
he hopes to be leading with in a matter
of months Tom Rainer Sky News Brighton